claude blanchemaison bonjour bonjour
très heureux de vous retrouver dans la
matinale de rtl france alors qu'elle
jure jans en afghanistan aujourd'hui
vont traiter les dirigeants du g7
le jour c'est évidemment d'évacuer tous
les tous ceux qui veulent partir
étrangers et afghans et de les évacuer
d'ici le 31 août on sait que ce sera
très difficile et la vie d'un certain
nombre de pays européens dont la
grande-bretagne et la france c'est que
ce sera même impossible or les talibans
refuse de prolonger ce délai ils ont dit
très clairement il y aurait des
conséquences si les troupes américaines
étaient encore à l'aéroport le lendemain
du 31 août quand ils disent américaine
cela veut dire troupes étrangères en
réalité est par ailleurs ils ont dit
qu'il ne formerait le gouvernement le
fameux gouvernement inclusif temps
qu'ils ont promis la formation qu'une
fois toutes les troupes étrangères
partie donc il n'y aura pas de
gouvernement à kaboul tant que cette cet
élément ne sera pas réalisée alors
effectivement certains se demandent s'il
ya une marge de négociation le ministre
des affaires étrangères allemand avait
évoqué hier
par exemple la négociation d'une
possibilité de continuer les évacuations
avec les talibans une fois les troupes
étrangères partie cette hypothèse
n'existe probablement pas et c'est en
tout cas l'avis des américains qui
considèrent que sous leurs sous leur
surveillance est déjà actuellement
extrêmement difficile puisqu'il ya
fréquemment des différends avec les
talibans qui ont tour à l'extérieur
l'aéroport qui ont installé des check
polt et qui contrôlent évidemment
l'identité des talibans qui traverse ces
checkpoints et certains sont empêchés
d'accéder à l'aéroport donc c'est une
situation très difficile on pourrait
penser aussi que
le mollah qui est qui et a pris le
leadership mollah baradar dans cette
affaire pourrait être tenté de négocier
avec les américains avec le représentant
spécial américain qui était son
interlocuteur après tout pendant deux
ans entre 2018 et 2020 à doha pour
renégocier le retrait américain qui
était prévu pour le 1er mai et que les
américains ont reporté au 31 31 août
pour obtenir quelque chose du côté les
occidentaux alors obtenir quoi la
reconnaissance du g7 par exemple mais il
l'a déjà finalement puisque les
américains ont négocié avec lui pendant
deux ans ou bien le déblocage des
réserves de devises étrangères de la
banque centrale de l'afghanistan qui
sont actuellement bloqués aux états unis
mais les choses ne vont pas dans ce sens
est aujourd'hui l'humeur n'est pas à la
négociation
et justement quels sont les leviers
d'action des puissances du g7
s'il y en a alors les guides actions si
d'abord les américains vont vouloir
garder le contrôle de la manne heures
ils vont ils veulent de l'appui du g7
pour les lots ciation qui pourrait avoir
lieu avec les talibans dans les
prochains jours parmi les éléments qui
pourraient d'intervenir ce sont des
éléments en effet
distingue c'est d'abord la formation
d'un gouvernement inclusif qui
marquerait la volonté des talibans
d'ouvrir le champ politique est de
gouverner avec
l'ensemble des représentants de la
société afghane
c'est peu vraisemblable qu'ils ouvriront
beaucoup probablement ils auront le
soutien de karzaï et de la lave d'allah
qui participait
au gouvernement précédent mais il est
clair qu'ils veulent d'appliquer la
charia
cela
reste à démontrer en suivant quelle
quelle interprétation puisqu'il est là
prête à options souples dans lesquels
les femmes peuvent étudier peuvent
travailler et on les droits proches de
ceux des hommes mais ils ont dit
clairement que ce serait le cas
probablement mais dans le cadre de la
loi islamique alors que veut dire dans
le cas de la loi islamique
ça reste à démontrer et c'est
probablement ce qui sera évoquée au
conseil des droits de l'homme
aujourd'hui par ailleurs évidemment il
ya toute la vie militaire les
médicaments n'arrive plus à kaboul
puisqu'il ya plus de voix le civil il
n'y a plus non plus l'aide américaine
l'aide occidentale les organisations
financières internationales ont suspendu
leur lors de leurs opérations lors leurs
prêts leur don par conséquent l'argent
l'extérieur n'arrive plus et il n'est
pas sûr que les chinois aient
l'intention la possibilité de prendre la
relève claude il nous reste quelques
secondes mais cette dernière question
avec qui les gouvernements occidentaux
doivent discuter aujourd'hui
les américains sont sont ceux qui
discutent au nom des occidentaux et ils
ont choisi de discuter avec les talibans
puisque dès 2018 ils ont discuté pendant
deux ans à douar avec cette équipe
talibane
dirigé par le mollah que je citais tout
à l'heure alors effectivement cette
discussion continue et elle est tout à
fait normal d'ailleurs elle a lieu en ce
moment pour les passages des checkpoints
qu à l aéroport et c'est tout à fait
normal puisque les militaires sur le
terrain ont toujours l'habitude de
discuter avec les autres militaires
lorsqu'il ya des lignes de contrôle
lorsqu'il ya des lignes de cessez le feu
maintenant sur le plan politique la
question se posera pour les
gouvernements occidentaux de savoir
s'ils acceptent de discuter avec le
gouvernement qui sera formé dans les
prochaines semaines et s'il par
conséquent il reconnaît son existence en
tant que représentant du peuple afghan
là aussi ça reste à voir ça dépend de sa
composition certains pays ont annoncé
qu'ils ne reconnaîtraient pas un tel
gouvernement la doctrine française
traditionnelle et que on n'a pas
véritablement reconnaître formellement
un gouvernement c'est les autorités en
place contrôlant réellement la situation
qui y ont démontré qu'elles contrôlent
la situation
sans les autorités avec lesquelles on
discute merci beaucoup claude blanche
raison pour votre éclairage un édito à
retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux